I have Nicol SP with reason TV and today
we're talking with William de Eggers and
John O'Leary authors of if we can put a
man on the moon getting big things done
in government and it's a nice reunion of
sorts you guys worked at recent
foundation back in the 90s when well it
wasn't quite the organization it is now
I mean it was the farm to now but let's
talk about the book first obviously the
error in the title if we can put a man
on the moon if we can fake putting a man
on the yeah talk about the moon program
because I mean it's the controlling
metaphor if your book was the moon
program a success or that were in what
ways was it in what ways was it a
failure well we look at things not from
the decision whether or not it was a
good idea to go to the moon we look at
in the book is did government
successfully execute on what it set out
to do and by that criteria the moon the
Apollo program was a success because in
1961 Kennedy in Congress said we're
going to go to the moon by the end of
the decade and they clearly got there so
by that criteria of success we look at
some of the factors that made it a
success and compared to actually some
more recent failures from NASA when it
would be roughly everything after the
moon lander nASA has absolutely
struggled as an agency since then the
Columbia and Challenger disasters we
look at in the book rather extensively
but we also actually just look at the
advantages that James Webb who is the
main administrator throughout most of
the 60s had because it was largely a
start-up organization and he was not
encumbered by many of the personnel and
administrative rules that the people who
run NASA today are burdened with one of
the one of the traps that we talked
about in the book is called the
overconfidence trap and very often
they'll talk about government programs
and they'll put of certain budget on
them and and they'll say it's gonna end
in three years and we'll finish it and
oftentimes it's almost always cost
overruns and time overruns and what Webb
did to avoid that was when Kennedy
originally said we want to put a man on
the moon
1968 I think it was and Webb said no it
has to be by the end of the decade
because he wanted to build in that time
and when they originally put their cost
estimate on he knew that they were prone
to kind of the overconfidence and so he
I think he doubled yeah he roughly
doubled yes double the estimate and so
they came pretty close
so they actually met the the hopeful
budget what talk about a recent example
of a big government project that is just
a total screwup a total quagmire let's
not even talk about foreign policy
because we could be here all time but I
mean what what's a good example of
people have asked us what is a big
success in in recent history and it is
difficult to look at large government
undertaking it's easier to thing look at
things that didn't go through
immigration reform 2006 failed to become
reality No Child Left Behind in 2001
clearly hasn't been a success you
wouldn't necessarily describe it as a
total fiasco but clearly didn't deliver
the hope for results I think that the
foreign policy issues the Katrina is
sort of a poster child
Boston's Big Dig is the largest
infrastructure project in American
history
horrible cost over what if what if it is
that the point of these projects is not
act you know and this is kind of a
public choice or in a cult reading of
government activity the point of the Big
Dig or the point of No Child Left Behind
isn't to actually improve education it
is to spend money it's to come up with a
plausible pretext to just employ a lot
of people and spend more and more gobs
of money I think both sides make the
mistake of they have what we call
Tolstoy syndrome or confirmation bias
there they don't let diverse viewpoints
and they don't like criticism come in
and they basically have this sort of
tunnel vision and what would ends up
happening there is you have a bad idea
and you're never going to be successful
with the idea is bad in the first place
and I think you know one of the things
that we point out in the book that it's
it's both you know the left and the
right that that make those mistakes
because we've also seen a lot of
failures in recent years of market
oriented small government downsizing
initiatives that failed and then my
ideas may have been great but their
execution was poor
so talk a little bit about what goes
into the proper planning and execution
of a good idea of a big project that
gets them well part of it is I mean the
idea has to be good one of the things we
do in the book which sort of violates
the rule of writing about government
undertakings is that we look at both the
policy development side of things and
the implementation bureaucratic side of
things generally you're right about
policy and politics or you're right
about public management and we looked at
the journey to success the journey
starting with an idea and going all the
way through results as being a
continuous journaling journey and when
you take those two apart artificially
you'll lose a lot of insights that you
gained by looking at them as a
continuous process because a lot of the
failures that we see in implementation
have their roots in poor legislative
design I think California electricity
reform in the late 90s is a great
example of that it cost governor Gray
Davis the governorship in his in essence
and yet it had been passed unanimously
by the legislature and signed into law
by Governor Pete Wilson and yet Davis
was the guy who when this this plan blew
up and it wasn't really execute
implementation failures it was really
the design failures that then expressed
themselves during the implementation
phase so in that case you need a
workable design that's going to stand up
in the real world and oftentimes we do
these designs just to get them through
the legislatures and they don't work in
the real world that's a big problem you
need to make sure when you're going
through Congress or a state legislature
that the idea doesn't get so distorted
that it's not going to work you need to
have you know a good launch for this and
another thing that we found was most of
these successful initiatives whether
they were small government initiatives
or big government initiatives were
characterized by what we call the
bridger as someone in the bureaucracy
who is really good at bridging the
public and that I mean the politicians
the political side and the bureaucratic
side and essentially they knew the
public sector terrain which is so
different than the private sector and
they can navigate that terrain if you
don't have someone like that it's very
very difficult to be sitting with us
what's a good success story one of the
things we point to is in
than they instituted congestion pricing
which basically means you charge people
to drive in downtown London during
during work days and the thing that we
found interesting about that was that it
was implemented this is a market
oriented reform in essence it's a
difficult one politically to sell but
they had their socialist mayor
environmental reasons use these market
oriented approach that you know Milton
Friedman and other sort of economists
would would would say yes that makes
sense to allocate resources more
efficiently
Bob Poole at The Reason Foundation has
been advocating this sort of thing for a
long time another success in a similar
vein was acid rain reductions from the
1980s which used a cap-and-trade model
and it was a accommodate it was
developed by an economist but it it
again uses market mechanisms to take on
environmental concerns and the
interesting thing I find about kind of
both the California electricity was
called electricity deregulation Road and
was based on this market approach of
choice and competition is going to drive
electricity prices down
but if you design that poorly you can
get into enormous difficulty which
California did which did I mean they
limited the market the deregulation
produced a document that was a foot high
right and in the same way the
cap-and-trade that was very successful
in the 1980s doesn't mean that something
else that's called cap-and-trade is
going to be successful it's all in those
design details that if those aren't
right if the markets aren't shaped
correctly or the incentives aren't
aligned you can have massive problem how
important is it to make sure that you're
that government is only doing certain
types of things because this is you know
in a libertarian organization when it
you know it might even be that the
government could do certain things
efficiently but it shouldn't do them but
then typically government takes on too
much stuff well you know there's
actually two different ways of looking
at that the first one is simply from the
standpoint of non non take Audiology out
of it completely but what we heard from
a lot of the senior executives in
government that we interviewed and that
we surveyed was that they actually
believe that when government is trying
to do too many things then there's a
lack of focus on getting these big
things right and
and so you know what we talked about in
one of our traps is we call the
complacency trap essentially and that's
when we have a lot of programs and
systems and agencies that have built up
over time and that we continue to
essentially do those we haven't really
ated them we haven't looked at them and
we spend a lot of time and energy
managing those in a lot of managerial
talent and that then distracts from
getting some of the more important
things done that we think so take away
ideology completely you have some real
operational problems from failing to
reexamine government choosing wisely is
a critical step and so I think that it's
it's essential that we do make good
choice about what we ask government to
do and I also think that understanding
how government works which this book
looks at is it can only enhance our
decision-making in terms of making those
choices about what we ask government to
do I want to thank Bill Eggers and John
O'Leary authors of the great new book if
we can put a man on the moon getting big
things done in government first talking
to Reason TV today I'm Nicholas